yeah welcome to this video a new
five-minute game against grandmaster
Goff's teen i hope i pronounced is
correct and correctly from israel and we
get a new so Indians a mesh variation 98
is very important move to prevent Bishop
g5 f4 f5 probably oh no Bishop e3 this
is some isn't played that often nowadays
mm yeah just d 60 is there some some
better move 96 not shown d6 f4 f5 yeah
probably this is still a ride yeah there
was some alternatives night g3 so yeah
shut up Lynette a4 a5 now hmm yeah f4 f5
or some dangerous plan but I don't think
I'm much much choice came
yeah maybe Roxy eight I can try a queen
d7a for winning the porn okay it is a
risky risky business but okay I can play
a five film can i play a five and he
might have d5
f5 he plays d5 here this is so this is a
problem but I can take your form now
maybe it is still alright hmm yeah the
the negative thing that is very easy to
play white s only moves and I'm spending
lots of time as usual so Knight f6 maybe
I need to get the eighth night into play
hmm yeah maybe here I overlooked
something he's got Bishop f5 where I can
I take rook only three I intended to
exchange to Susac the exchange here this
is this is not a blunder I want to to
get see form and then establish a night
on c4 Bishop c4 Pepsi 494 I hope that
this is some compensation
you
Kim Bishop c4 if I get in light to see
for and can um wow okay I need to take
that yeah Queen takes I'd like to get
the Queen's off this would be would be
helpful even I hope maybe a maybe I'm
not judging this right his King is also
quite weak may be here so that I can
play 94 yeah well it's just shoving
everything forward without much thought
to be honest um it's probably not even
good for him but of course it's not easy
to play okay maybe take center should be
5 SS the DM
now my queen is not not helping maybe
get them get the Queen back to d7
95mm yeah he's got f7 anyway
yeah this is very dangerous yeah if six
was strong after all you played this
very quickly Jack
check check that is a major even
rook f6 I'm just trying to see the mate
there should be a maid ok this is this
is probably enough look at phone mate I
can give this check on 11 spy check it's
allowed to give one spy check come on
here it's it's lost anyway i can play
rook a form ok for as major let's play
to meet ya yeah i played this well very
quickly maybe I'm cam I don't know I
actually don't think this should be you
should be so great for white young it
takes d5 her son it's a good for black
but ok i was i was planning this
planning this exchange sacrifice i
actually thought that d take c6 was much
stronger but ok you play everything
instantly so and now this is no Bishop
g5 is good for white but he played this
instantly and now i can take seafoam
yeah this is certainly a ride for black
I cannot believe that this should be so
great it's got a wide-open King and I've
got to get a pawn
now @ g5f six is really strong them now
yeah it's difficult very difficult to
play we are taking taking their now as
stronger group the eight losses losses
and move can I can take take now gypsy
phone yeah difficult game yeah thanks
for watching